out there there are any number of
organizations the New York Times is one
of them the big foundations are another
universities many of them are complicit
in this in many ways have a very
distinct political agenda now political
agendas involve moral campuses and
that's fine as long as you respect
to my mind the basic what logic evidence
truth the search for truth and the surf
the truth has been suspended in favor of
social justice in other words I mean I
don't think that you can have social
justice and not have the truth
in fact it's very dangerous because if
you or you know if you if you put social
justice as the end of what your inquiry
that leads you very very dangerous
places because who's to say with social
justices what are the problems with
World culture is that it's it's uh on
both sides I think a mistake about scale
so on the one hand of course there's a
huge scale there's uh the history of
slavery in the United States which is
this massive profound thing which
infects everything the architecture of
the Cities the
um the uh you know the economy of of
many parts of the country still
um and so that seems very big but it it
it can't be addressed on a large scale
it has to be addressed with real people
with real human beings in a way that has
a real impact on their lives and the
same at a university you have many
groups of people as Leon was talking
about lots of universities are more
diverse than they used to be
and you have also universities uh
reducing everything to economies of
scale so they're they're teaching at a
mass level these people from all over
there's no Community there's no respect
for the individual there's no sense that
um the inevitable conflicts that are
going to arise when you mix these people
together have to be resolved in real
human relationships person to person and
face to face so I I just want to say I
think this the the the problem of
education is a in in it's it's very very
big but it's also very very small
there's a there's a local aspect to it
and same with what culture there's a lot
to the commute I've seen incredible
difficulties diffused by a conversation
I've seen it again and again and again
and I've seen real reconciliation take
place in conversation between real human
beings one of whom is suffering and one
of whom caused the suffering and that's
that's seems to be the place where
um we should be thinking about because
it's it's not going to be solved at the
level of
um destroying global capitalism or
encouraging global capitalism promoting
democracy or whatever it's going to be
solved by peop real human beings
gathering together and using what forces
they have to make
[Applause]
[Music]
I think certainly in America we are
suffering from a disastrous over
politicization politicization of the
entirety of life
I think it used to be that Democrats and
liberals and conservatives liberals and
conservatives one of the few things they
could agree on was the limits of
politics
that there are places into which
politics should not be allowed to
penetrate and one of those Realms would
be culture I hope though of course as we
know from totalitarian Societies in
order for that politics to succeed
culture is the very first place they
want to penetrate
politics should not penetrate in what
Sean called the search for truth
you know in this we are a journal that I
edit we chose a motto from maimonides
every issue has this sentence from
maimonides and the sentence is accept
the truth from whoever utters it
when you think of it that way you
de-politicized the conversation
completely later you can get into the
irony or the outrage that so and so has
the temerity to say X and Y but the
first thing you need to do when you hear
X and Y is ask is it true is it true and
if you are not asking about the truth of
the proposition first then you have
allowed politics to enter into a place
where it does not belong